presumably you know meeting the people
on the show is one thing
but there must be lots of people who
can't be bothered to apply who then just
see you
and go david meaden listen to my idea
uh that happens quite a lot that does
happen quite a lot actually kobe has
been quite a nice break from that you
know i've actually been having been on
the streets but now that does happen a
lot and
and it's in the you know i can remember
once i was i was at a railway station
about to get on the train to paddington
trains turning up in 10 minutes lady
behind the screen says to me
so glad i've seen you my son's got a
brilliant idea and i'm thinking we're
okay because i've got to buy a ticket
and i've got to get on the train
so it can't be long so we're chatting
about five minutes you can imagine
agitation behind me there's about 30
people queuing up
and i said um i'm on the paddington
train is there and she said oh don't
worry dear it's 20 minutes late
so i wasn't popular now i am worried yes
you